the holidays are a time of giving in
chicago west clearly understood the
assignment when she gave fans this look
i finally have a really good idea for
christmas and it was a doozy kim
kardashian
sharing skim's christmas card to social
media featuring her children shy song
fame and northwest chloe's daughter true
rob's daughter dream and mom kris jenner
i'm obsessed with all of the you know
holidays and decorating the kardashians
christmas cards are a staple of the
season but one family member stole the
show this holiday
chicago west is getting all the
attention for her pose in this photo
where the three-year-old looks
photoshoot ready and she's receiving a
lot of comparisons to kendall jenner's
model looks
i'm super excited let's see shai and
kendall side by side
[Music]
oh yeah the resemblance is definitely
there and twitter agreed reactions
included comments like quote chicago is
coming for auntie kendall's job and
quote chicago is a natural watch out
kendall
shai also recently appeared on kim and
north's tick tock showing a glimpse of
how they spent christmas
and this post followed shy sister
northwest debuting her new braces
oh my gosh i got my braces
shy standout moment comes after another
kardashian stole the holiday spotlight
yeah one sec
court just showed me i'm really lazy
leading up to christmas kim pointed out
courtney's elf on a shelf game is on a
whole other level
this is what she showed me this year
that i am really
lazy
and we need to get it together in the
final days
courtney and penelope's tick tock
account also highlighted the impressive
display featuring a quick cameo from
penelope's cousin northwest
o
n
g
r l
are like
crazy
kim also gave a tour of quartz winter
wonderland home
even getting sentimental at the site of
some special decorations
oh my gosh
the forest in here
is so
beautiful with these roses
you guys these used to be at my mom and
dad's house these
santa claus and mrs claus and reindeer
since we were born
wow court you really know how to do it
up and the mogul wasn't the only one
feeling nostalgic kris jenner shared
these throwback photos to instagram
gifting fans with a peek at holidays of
days past for the kardashians and
jenners
chris paid tributes all of her kiddos in
the caption writing quote christmas
memories happy holidays to each and
every one of you
[Music]
you